leute wir müssen unser bestes alte
wegschmeißen und das ist einfach dieser
würde ich sagen wenn wir diese
wegschmeißen haben wir keine mehr alter
wie soll ich das machen services kids
ich bin elvis presley und ich begrüße
euch herzlich zu einer neuen folge
minecraft ich habe heute wieder eine
challenge für euch am start
und zwar lautet die challenge wie folgt
ich würde sie einfach die großzügigkeit
management und zwar funktioniert die so
ich werde dem ersten menschen dem ich im
deathmatch begegne mein bestes seiten
geben
kurz und knackig das ist die ganze
geschichte was das beste item sein wird
wird sie natürlich als die laufende
runde raus stellen
abhängig davon wie viele kisten ich
bekomme habe ich natürlich auch bessere
items sich red mir trotzdem volle mühe
geben die runde zu ende zu spielen so
weit wie möglich zu kommen muss dann
aber am ende abgeben was das ist welches
das wichtigste altem ist das liegt jetzt
in meinem ermessen das beste alter mann
nicht ihr dürft aber auch sehr gerne in
den kommentaren mit reden ich weiß
natürlich nicht wie gleich aussieht ist
es eventuell so dass es ganz eindeutig
ist was das beste team ist weil ich
irgendwie
bei aspect 25 31 die schwert habe und er
wird nicht klar sein dass ich den frage
auf jeden fall spielen wir jetzt erstmal
diese runde
ich darf mich auch gerne was von dem
zweiten dritter in berlin erzählen
gehabt von dem ersten drehtag er den
video gesehen
der zweite drehtag war ultra stressig
ich weiß gar nicht was ich an aufnahmen
habe ich habe glaube ich eine aufnahme
vom frühstück morgens im hotel könnte
ich mir vier ist prezi wache recht das
war verrückt man hatte es ist ein wunder
dass ich diesen tag überlebt habe ich
habe mir morgens 4 oder 4 4 ist presse
glaube ich in eine kaffeetasse gemacht
also in vierfache nespresso quasi so
ging es mir eine morgen hat das schon
ein paar nächte zu wenig geschlafen
diese nach gott sei dank mehr und es war
so die vier wie gesagt ich vierter
fünfter nachdem folge mit 45 stunden
schlafen das ist halt auf weg für mich
einfach zu wenig und dann musste mir ein
bisschen was bei einer rein ball an und
somit ein versprechen gemacht werden
dass das habe ich noch als ausnahme
dann habe ich glaube ich darüber hinaus
noch eine aufnahme in der ich am set
stehe
und irgendwie sage ich was von saft
einfach orangensaft ich habe mir extra
für diesen spruch einen orangensaft
gemacht was man ihr als macht- und
fassbar
ich habe extra und wiesen spruch sagen
zu können da einen orangensaft selbst
gepresst eigenhändig habe ich die
orangen durch die saftpresse leider so
und ich brauche mal nicht holzschwert
tombola taliban
wir müssen uns heute den weg macht wir
müssen ja nicht okay wie sieht's aus
einer ziemlich weit vorne
hoffentlich müssen wir leben ja nicht
unsere altem aufgeben ist es ja noch das
wärs ja noch der crs der jump'n'run ab
da würde doch unser item wenn der winter
ist glaub mir okay diese parkour ist mir
nichts kann
um ehrlich zu sein würde sagen wir bauen
hier um ok go on ice alter stark ist
aber stark ist und ich immer so eine
sache weil das stärkste muss im
zweifelsfall dann abgeben wenn die
optimale strategie ist aber so geht's
auf jeden fall ja ok alles klar also die
change ist mit ihm spontan eingefallen
manchmal habe ich so kurz vor der
aufnahme momente wo ich mir denke sobald
die challenges geil das machen wir
oder eben nicht und dann kommt irgendwas
anderes aber was ich eigentlich sagen
wir leute ich bin mir gar nicht sicher
ob ich noch einen zweiten videos
schneiden kann bin mir ziemlich sicher
dass ich keinen zweiten videos schneiden
kann ich habe mich darüber hinaus noch
meine kamera in berlin vergessen und es
ist noch nicht mal klar wurde jetzt ist
ein bisschen ab aber andererseits
schockiert mich auch wie gleichgültig
demgegenüber bin also irgendwie so
normalerweise müsste ich viel mehr
viel mehr aufregende aber das war eine
kamera weg ist irgendwie mache ich das
gar nicht das finde ich seltsam letzter
zeit bin ich so gleichgültig vielen
vielen dingen gegenüber machen ein
bisschen angst aber vielleicht kennt ihr
das ja auch könnt ihr auch morgen
reinschreiben so alles wieder zu
erfreulicheren team und nicht mein alter
schwede man 370 blöcke was ist los mit
dem jungen ja kommt dass es mit der 1
nein ich mag so diese ganz ganz englisch
bürger nicht so wirklich lieber die ok
schaffen und jetzt ein
tricky und dann haben wir hier sehr
schön okay weiter im text
lasst uns möglich gute items unsere
gegner bekommen so max ruft mich was
geht max mordhorst geht es bei dir
dr hallo müsste deshalb glaube ich ja
ich nehme ist auch das ding du was ich
jetzt mache was ich ja ich habe auch
gesehen hat noch 51 prozent gehabt aber
ich hab den browser offen gelassen
worte müssen es rein ziehen jetzt in der
aufnahme ja komm runter
das sind fünf sekunden moment lasst uns
das man ja die safe point suchen so
check point man tiefer krater war diana
aufzuholen okay also die doppel
challenge heute jetzt auch noch mit dem
bruder der noch ein bisschen rein fiktiv
ihren gelegenheiten so sagt in den
gebilden kreisen auch wieder reinkommen
jetzt profitiert vom organisierten
desktop finden aber recht schnell
gefunden dafür dass es einfach nur offen
habe 202 heißt er hat dafür einen augen
entwickelt ballereien sprechen speichern
gut 50 danke dass du mir so sehr die
aufnahme vorteile
ok egal
nice der sprung nicht wieder der
schwierigste ich hoffe ich habe jetzt
hier nicht vergessen ich glaub ja die
schere die tester die warum warum nenne
ich sowas checks das ist weder ein
tschechisches klett noch sonst irgendwas
ist einfach nur ab was wisst ihr was ich
behalte die items war
ich behalte die alte zwar für den fall
dass sie einst von den weg geben muss
habe ich sie immer noch als duplikat
vorlegen ich hab dann noch im zeitfahren
das ich einen guten strategie biete ich
biete limone ok 19 aber ich bin wieder
der spitze leute sehr gut ich hab mich
noch nach vorne gearbeitet hätte ich
nicht gedacht
er hatte er teilweise 200 blöcke
vorsprung haben torwart wird warte
wo ist bei dem teil nochmal die kiste
ich finde die nie
ich finde bei diesem parcours ungelogen
nie kiste wo es sie ja okay da ist auf
jeden fall schon mal nicht kommission
und vielleicht nein geilo okay naja ok
ich gebe mir mal nicht geben herr sind
gibt es ihn glaubt wissen über den
wirklichen sound heute in der aufnahme
müsste entschuldigen wieder zehn gramm
gehauchte vor aber man muss halt auch
brauchen
bitte nehmt es nicht zu ernst war nicht
so scheiße aber ich bin keine ahnung was
kann mir los ist vollkommen vielleicht
ist es der elvis presley mehr der gerade
die kontrolle übernimmt
ich will jetzt gern elvis presley trinkt
kann sein tempo ich glaube leute wir
müssen unser bestes alte wegschmeißen
und das ist einfach diese arien jazz
plate würde ich sagen wenn wir diese
alles wegschmeißen haben wir keinen
respekt mehr alter wie soll ich das
machen
what the [ __ ] ok abfall kriegst du dir
hier
ich hoffe du hast spaß damit jetzt muss
ich mir überlegen wie ich diesen
aggressiven zeitgenossen damir vom leib
halten was wir könnten jetzt nicht geben
faktor okay dann hab ich natürlich nicht
gerade das neugeschäft mit dem sollte
also ich habe jetzt nur daran gedacht
okay einstein schweizweit estate wird
zetsche zitiert das wird richtig
schwierig vor allem bei der sonst ein
zweiter kommt sonst hätte ich gesagt ich
nehme mir jetzt mal das war vor den
typen hier neue leute immer teurer denn
alleine würde ich sagen ich auf was ein
double dip ergebnis von david zieht mir
zwei herzen
zwei herzen drei herzen habe ich mit 2 1
okay ich hab jetzt ein richtiges problem
ich habe einfach keine jazz blade of
care geht mir aber doppelt neben eco
boost mich noch mal es ist so schwierig
alte das ist so schwierig wisst ihr was
ich verstecke mich jetzt ich verstecke
mich oder es sei denn einer kommt dieses
designs ok dat noch drei leben das
projekt überhaupt nichts gegen jetzt
kämpfen wobei dieser stefan raab noch
ein leben stefan hat nur noch ein leben
stefan stefan stefan macht stress macht
kein stress ich habe ein herzen nehmen
in denen stefan ja auch kopf nein nein
nein nein nein nein ich hab ich hab nix
leute ich bin nicht interessant ich bin
überhaupt interessant es lohnt sich zu
töten
es lohnt sich überhaupt nicht mich zu
töten nein macht es nicht macht ist
einfach nicht das macht wirklich keinen
sinn das ist schlechtes karma was das
alter schwede jetzt also ob gott ist
verfolgte mich so peter verstehe es
nicht mal ich hab doch gar nix
das habe ich den was ja interessieren
könnte vorher habe ich eines und zwar
keine chance mit dem equipment
gold erreicht hat schon wenn ich jetzt
eine chat bekommen würde
ich würde ja reingehen aber so ist das
sei schwierig muss jetzt echt auf den
abstauber spekulieren
ok dieser elfer chrome hat noch drei
leben manchmal als abgezogen ich würde
sagen ein knappes jahr vor seiner der
andere kommt jetzt auf den moment moment
wir müssen jetzt krass taktisch spielen
extrem wenig leben und vor allem müssen
wir oft dafür sorgen dass wenn ich das
wenn ich auf einmal ohne food darstellen
alter diese changes schwierig dies hat
wirklich schwierig das wird man richtig
richtig krasser struggle ok wack rom
wurde von dem mann getötet
manche irrt manchmal ich jetzt gerne
echt echt gerne der menschen die kelter
dran
ich sollte mich fällt an diesen elfer
combo halten den könig verlor beim
ersten kind auf jeden fall nicht fehlen
sie können sich aber auch das heck wird
man alter schwede
ok ich das ist meine einzige chance
lasst uns überlegen wie man ja ich hab
meine einzige chance ist wirklich zu
warten bis einer von denen ein leben hat
geschwächt ist und dann zuzuschlagen
sonst habe ich keine chance oder chat
oder doch emma forever forever kommt für
den doch so reichen
lies was wir dropped wie könnt ihr
droppen hat er nur ein leben
wir haben geschäftsfeld alter ja es hat
geklappt
die strategie aufgegangen wir haben eine
cashback eine gute aber immerhin einer
brüstung punkte lesen schon mal wichtig
ich glaube der mich doch das sieht es
mit relativ viel ausmacht ehrlich gesagt
vor allem wenn die anderen reisenden
chefs am vielleicht kennt jetzt kurz vor
1 abstauben
also wie gesagt abstauben trifft den
nagel auf den kopf muss extrem taktisch
spielen und wenn man keine sorgen zu
machen was ich will jetzt auch auf gar
keinen fall sterben heißt ich darf mir
keine combo verhalten der 5 modus dann
glaube ich hat er oder hat er nicht ich
glaube nicht wir können wir einen
mitgeben und wird es was
wird es was ich weiß nicht es ist halt
echt kritisch ich habe nur noch ein
einziges leben ich glaube ich dass dies
ein bisschen liefen wie krass das wäre
wenn wir die challenge schaffen würden
wie krass wenn nicht würde ich mich dann
bisschen ärgern aber man könnte es mir
nicht mehr übernehmen weil die echt
schwierig ist ohne kate und ihren alle
ihren chefs allein ich hatte davor drei
abrüstungs punkte leute allein der deren
album test gibt denn so viel schutz wie
davor alle rüstungsteile zusammen die
ich hatte nie kommt macht ihr mal euer
ding beenden spectators pakete ich will
dass einer von denen nur noch ein leben
hat dieses designs ist geschwächt ich
könnte mir den vorknöpfen mir geht aber
auch langsam der food aus das ist jetzt
echt ein problem langsam
ich glaube der andere hatte auch kein
food männer zu machen wir es am besten
die kämpfen kämpfen kämpfen kämpfen
kämpfen sehr gut sehr gut sehr gut
ok ich hab' eingeholt hp ist die vision
das dürfte reichen aufzuholen und die
andere ist auch dann noch zwei kids wir
reden jetzt über die regions heißt wir
müssen erstmal nicht essen
er schreibt opfer junge du weißt sie wie
es mir gerade geht man das ist das
flagge darüber hinaus besuchen [ __ ]
wurde auch vor schreibst aber ok go play
next to the middle with you ok hat er
das spiel verloren
jetzt kann er seine vorteile ausspielen
seinen kompletten rüstungs vorteil
wir müssen jetzt richtig hart mit der
angel arbeiten wo ist die mitte wo ist
die mittel
nein nein ich konnte mich kommt bisher
als halbes jahr als mittel muss die
mittel musste mitteln ich weiß es nicht
er schafft es alter schwede
morales kraftakt das war echt heftig
schwierige sache probiert ist auch gerne
mal aus und finale ohne jazz plate am
ende ist sie aber ja